dr. Joe Franklin earned his BA in
Psychology away
University which let me tell you is a
great psych program to graduate from
because I also did so we have that in
common and he went to graduate school at
UNC Chapel Hill and he has been very
prolific and winning fellowships and
awards since then he did a postdoctoral
fellowship at Harvard with dr. Ngoc and
in 2015 started in the clinical science
program as an assistant professor at
Vanderbilt University he's gonna tell us
about some of his very interesting work
with smartphone apps and suicide
detection and Prevention today it's
really fascinating when we talk about
assessment when we talk about how do we
identify the people that are most risk
he's really going to touch on something
that we haven't done as much yet in
research or in clinical work with so I
know people are trickling in so please
come in and have a seat and I will turn
the mic over to dr. Franklin thank you
[Applause]
great thank you very much and it's
awesome to be there here again my name
is Joe and today I'm going to be talking
about how some recent radical changes
and research have substantially advanced
suicide risk detection and prevention
just over the last year or so so first
why do we even need to try to make these
radical changes in our approach well a
big reason is actually this red line
right here and this red line represents
the u.s. suicide rate over about the
last 35 years so as you've heard before
and in this New York Times article it
has increased a bit recently but really
since the year 2000 close to 25% and
actually if you extend this out to the
year 1900 it's a fairly flat line where
it's pretty close to 10 or so all the
way back since we've really been keeping
records so this actually stands in stark
contrast over these 35 years to the
major reductions that we've been able to
see and things like deaths due to motor
vehicle fatalities and that's due to
homicide so to me this is absolutely
unacceptable because I think as many of
you think that all of these suicide
deaths are actually preventable and it's
not just suicide deaths so the rates of
suicide ideation plans and non-fatal
suicide attempts show a similar stagnant
a pattern if not a slight increase in
recent decades and this is despite
increases in treatment usage by
individuals reporting these issues over
the same time period so as researchers
and clinicians we should all be outraged
by this graph and the one that was on
the preceding slide and that's because
they demonstrate that whatever we've
been doing over the last 50 years or so
and suicide research it just really
simply hasn't been effective for the
things that we're most charged to take
care of so today I'm going to be talking
to you about how myself and some of my
colleagues have really been trying to
change the trajectories of these types
of graphs and we'll start by briefly
summarizing the entire history of
suicide risk detection
efforts through about the year 2014 as a
basic preview through about the year
2014 our ability to predict suicidal
thoughts and behaviors was essentially
on par with random guessing so second
I'm going to talk about how my
colleagues and I along with some other
groups have made some recent advances
beyond this state of affairs and finally
I'll end by talking about some recent
app based treatments that we've been
testing and a few different randomized
control trials so to start with risk
detection I'm gonna be describing it's
called a meta analysis or we just put a
bunch of studies together that my team
and I conducted over the last couple of
years that tested all risk factors for
suicidal thoughts and behaviors over a
50-year period and I want to bring your
attention here in this title to a very
important yet often misunderstood phrase
which is risk factor so risk factors are
obviously absolutely key to
understanding suicidal behaviors but
just like in many other fields
we're often very much inconsistent with
how we use the term risk factor so
sometimes whenever we use risk factor we
actually mean concomitant or a correlate
of something sometimes we actually use
it to mean a causal risk factor and
sometimes we really do use it to mean
risk factor but these three things are
not the same thing because the coral it
is associated with a given outcome the
directionality it's going to be unclear
this is where you have a lot of
cross-sectional or retrospective type
designs a risk factor will precede an
outcome and divide people into low and
high risk groups and this is where
longitudinal designs become really
really important and causal risk factors
changes and causal risk factors will
cause changes in levels of future risk
but again just like in many other fields
and the suicide field we've often
confused these terms whenever we've been
trying to describe things in our papers
whenever we've been trying to develop
lists of warning signs and risk factors
and whenever we've been developing our
theories and treatments but this
distinction has huge practical
implications for our field the
as core let's turn out to be poor
predictors and poor treatment targets
risk factors are generally going to be
good predictors but they may not be
great treatment targets and causal risk
factors are often good for both
prediction and treatment so it's
critical that we distinguish between
these things even when we see some
extremely strong and enticing
correlations both in your day-to-day
life and clinical work and even in
research for example over the last
several years this has been the pattern
of US suicide deaths by suffocation and
hanging over the same time period
another factor has shown nearly the
exact same pattern there any guesses as
to what this other factor might be close
it's a number of lawyers in North
Carolina
but good guess but it's not just North
Carolina we see the same pattern for the
number of lawyers in California and
before we start making theories about
lawyers and suicidal behaviors over the
last several years US suicide vests have
been powerfully correlated with things
like the cost of bananas average money
per household spent on pets and my
personal favorite is per capita
consumption of chicken so all of these
correlations are much much stronger than
what we would typically see in our own
research whenever we run our studies but
it's probably safe to assume that no
one's going to be proposing a theory
related to suicide and chickens or
bananas anytime soon or at least I would
hope not I would necessarily be all that
surprised
but generally this is because coral it's
just aren't gonna be that helpful for
helping us understand suicide they can
sometimes be very helpful as a first
step to see if something is generally
associated but it should just be that
first step we need to go far beyond that
to figure out what among the correlates
are actually risk factors so again this
highlights how important it is for us to
distinguish between these three types of
associations and again unfortunately in
our field there just aren't very many
studies of causal risk factors so we
don't have much information at all about
that kind of Association so what our
meta-analysis primarily focused on was
trying to disentangle correlates from
risk factors in particular we really
really wanted to know if there were
actually any significant risk factors
that existed at all and if so how strong
these risk factors might be so we hear a
lot about these things from clinical
practice we hear a lot about these
things from guidelines and we see them
from individual papers but whenever you
put the entire literature together what
really comes out what is really a risk
factor for suicidal thoughts or
behaviors so for the next few minutes
I'm going to be talking about for this
particular meta-analytic project some of
the assumptions that we carried going in
to this project then I'll give you a
brief overview of the methods and some
of the basic descriptive findings and
then I'll describe some actual
analytical results and then I'll talk
about a few implications of these
findings so first again to our
assumptions now based on the plethora of
risk factor and warning signs guidelines
out there we assumed going into this
project a couple of years ago that we
had some very solid knowledge about risk
factors we might not be perfect but we
had a pretty good idea of who was going
to be at risk and who wasn't we also
assumed that because science should be
progressive that since this whole field
of research and suicide predictions
started about 50 years ago that our risk
factor knowledge and ability to predict
future suicidal thoughts and behaviors
must have been steadily improving over
time and we were
almost 100 percent certain that things
like prior suicidal behavior
hopelessness depression people Civet e
things like that we're gonna come out as
being very powerful risk factors now in
terms of our methods to keep this part
of it short basically what we wound up
with after a lot of searching were 365
papers that qualified for the
meta-analysis all of these had to be
longitudinal and all of them had to use
some kind of factor at least one to try
and predict future suicidal thoughts
behaviors
so from these 365 papers we wind up with
over 4,000 of what we've termed
prediction cases and I'll describe a
little bit more about what that means
here in a moment but we were able to
convert 82% of these into a common
metric called an odds ratio which I'll
explain a little bit more a couple
slides from now and the other 18 percent
were hazard ratios which I won't go in
today but the results that I'll be
presenting on the odds ratios were
nearly identical to what we had found
for hazard ratios so I just mentioned
prediction cases and what do I actually
mean by this well for a given study a
single study may look at three different
risk factors so something like smoking
and depressant and impulsivity and it
may look at this across two different
types of outcomes suicide attempts and
suicide death and so each one of those
represents a separate prediction case a
separate attempt to use some kind of
factor to predict a future suicide
related outcome so on average each study
contained about 11 or 12 prediction
cases that we coded for so again within
our entire meta-analysis what we meta
analyzed really were those 4000
prediction cases all right so for the
next few slides what I really want to do
is start just by presenting some basic
descriptive findings from this project I
thought we're pretty interesting and one
of the first things that we noticed it
might not be that surprising is that the
number of papers in this area suicide
prediction has increase almost
exponentially over the last several
decades so really over the last ten
years more studies have been conducted
on this
and were conducted and all of history
before then and every year the number of
papers on this topic goes up almost by
half so as you might expect we see the
same pattern for those prediction cases
now another thing that we looked at were
follow-up links and we're actually kind
of surprised here because the majority
of studies actually looked at suicide
tried to predict suicide over extremely
long intervals as you can see here many
many of the studies actually had
follow-up links that were more than 10
years many more than five years and
comparatively few were even a year or
less in fact less than 1% of the studies
actually included follow-up intervals of
one month or less and to us this was
kind of disappointing and a little bit
surprising because as clinicians what
you're often charged with trying to
figure out is who's gonna be at risk
over the next few hours days or weeks
not quite as much who's going to be at
risk over the next 10 years or 20 years
it's very interesting to know that to
understand that but I think that this
should probably be flipped where most of
our research is on the very short
intervals with a little bit of research
on the very long intervals right so for
outcome types just to give you an idea
for what the outcomes look like and this
particular literature about 15 or so
percent of studies included suicidal
ideation as an outcome and then the
number that included attempts and and
death were much more and relatively few
look at things like plans and NSSI
although I will say that those are
increasing and frequency particularly as
non-suicidal self-injury research areas
is growing pretty quickly alright so in
terms of risk factors so the kinds of
things that people were using as
predictors in all of these studies what
really struck us was the extreme
homogeneity here so there were four
broad categories that accounted for
nearly 70% of all risk factor types that
anyone's ever tried to study and these
were things related to internalizing
psychopathology and externalizing and
prior self injurious thoughts and
behaviors
and demographic factors so the majority
of anything anyone's tried to predict
with it falls into one of these four
categories and adding another four
categories brings us to 95% of anything
anyone's ever looked at admittedly these
are fairly broad categories but out of
the near infinite things that we could
use to try and predict and understand
suicidal behaviors it's really come down
to just these few basic things
all right so in terms of our analytical
results again I'm one of our major
questions here was like are we actually
any good at all at predicting suicidal
ideation and attempts and death and to
try and figure this out we use something
called an odds ratio I know some of you
are familiar with this and some of you
might not be so I want to try to give a
brief primer on this over the next
couple of minutes so basically an odds
ratio is just a ratio and it's a ratio
of the odds of something happening and
one group compared to the odds of
something happening in another group so
for example the odds of someone dying by
suicide they've been diagnosed with
depression compared to the odds of them
dying by suicide if they have not been
diagnosed with depression so let's say
that we run this study and we get an
odds ratio of two indicating that people
who had been diagnosed with depression
were twice as likely or head twice as
high odds dying by suicide as people who
did not so that might be statistically
significant and might be interesting to
say there's a you know a hundred percent
increase among people who are depressed
but is that actually good and meaningful
in a clinical sense can you actually use
that will that actually influence your
day to day practice well to try to
figure out what it actually would mean
in a practical sense we can just do a
little bit of math and so according to
the CDC and 2013 about forty thousand
six hundred Americans died by suicide
but around three hundred and fourteen
million Americans did not so overall in
America and 2013 your odds of dying by
suicide were point zero zero zero one to
nine
almost zero now if we assume that
depression doubles those odds then you
move to point zero zero zero two five
eight so still essentially zero so no at
least practically and day to day and
when you're working with people
odds ratio of two isn't that helpful it
raises the odds of dying by suicide from
basically zero up to again basically
zero so one way to think about this is
actually at least I like to think about
it in terms of lottery tickets so let's
say that you have 100 lottery tickets
and I just have one well your relative
odds are amazing you are 100 times more
likely to win the lottery than I am but
you are still not going to win the
lottery
probably so your absolute ads are near
zero so the arts aren't quite as small
for dying by suicide certainly not as
small for attempting suicide are having
suicide ideation but as was mentioned
this morning the the base rates are
pretty low so whenever we're thinking
about this in a more global sense it's
important to keep that in mind so what
I'm about to show you in terms of the
results we're really looking for for
something that would be super meaningful
you for you on a day to day basis would
be some odds ratios and the hundreds or
at least in the tens that kind of thing
so to this question in order to answer
it you're gonna be seeing a couple of
graphs like this where on the y-axis
these are just weighted odds ratios
which long story short is just putting
all of the odds ratios from those
thousands of cases all together and
weighting them essentially based on
sample size and this line right here
will represent a chance level prediction
so an odds ratio of 1 equals chance
level prediction because it means the
odds and both groups are the same and
the error bars here will represent 95%
confidence intervals and the tighter
they are the more confident we are about
whatever level prediction that we're
getting so what do the results actually
look like well the odds weren't in the
hundreds or tens or anything at all like
that so overall whenever you put
everything
together you get stuff that's basically
right a chance level so right now
putting everything together our ability
to predict suicide ideation and attempts
and death are pretty close to an odds
ratio of 1 whatever you count for
publication bias because stronger
studies tend to get published then it
moves much closer to just you know
pretty much chance levels so know we are
we are not good not not at all
I don't have much time to discuss it
today but we also examine these findings
in terms of something called a
diagnostic accuracy rather than just
odds ratios so the results here show
that what's called areas under the curve
had an almost chance level somewhere you
know 0.5 4.57
to give you a little bit of an idea of
what that means basically areas under
the curve or AUC are gonna vary from 0.5
meaning absolutely random guessing about
something to 1.0 meaning absolute
perfect prediction about something and
typically and research are going to fall
somewhere in between there obviously our
our goals not just in this kind of
science but in medical science more
generally or the good as close to 1.0 as
you can but right now at least when
putting everything together our ability
after 50 years of research to predict
suicidal thoughts and behaviors is
essentially still at random guessing
alright so we looked at a lot of
moderators of this to see if any
possible variables might explain why
prediction is so poor overall you know
maybe and these kinds of studies it was
really good and those it was really
terrible and that explains it
but we didn't find that anything was a
significant moderator meaning that if
anything longer studies actually got you
a slightly worse prediction the more
severe your sample was the poor
lieutenant predict as well it didn't
really matter how many people you had in
your study from you know 20 or 30 to a
few thousand the results were about the
same and it didn't matter if you're
working with adolescents or adults or
the elderly or some mix thereof you're
just getting the same results across the
board so on the heels of these extremely
disappointing findings we were
just very curious as to whether our risk
factor knowledge had actually improved
at all over the last 50 years and I for
one was really certain that it had in
part because the number of studies has
increased dramatically over the last 50
years so you would expect again science
is progressive that you would see
something that at least vaguely
approximates this kind of linear
increase so what does the result
actually look like over time in terms of
prediction starting with ideation where
the first prediction of ideation study
was in 1991 weren't that good to start
and we've actually gotten significantly
worse since for suicide attempts not
that great to start either and you know
worse pretty much leveled off the last
30 years
and suicide death prediction was never
good I'm still not good so from my
colleagues and I this was pretty
shocking some of us has been in the
field for a while and wouldn't have
expected this kind of results some of us
hadn't appeal for a while and would have
expected this kind of result but it's
still it's still disappointing to see I
think a lot of other fields would
actually find the same thing if they did
similar analyses but for us this really
showed that our risk factor knowledge at
least in terms of accuracy of prediction
overall hadn't improved since this era
so from 1965 through 1984 and that was
really concerning because almost all the
studies have been conducted after that
time period which really you know starts
to question what do we learn from those
studies what was a necessity of those
studies and what can we do moving
forward not to repeat this again so that
was extremely disappointing for us but
these findings were focused on overall
predictions so pushing everything
together we thought doing that could be
a little bit unfair because maybe there
are some really amazing predictors that
are out there that are just really
getting washed out by putting everything
together so we're very very confident
that there were a few specific
predictors that would come out as being
very strong and we were absolutely wrong
so predicting suicide ideation so this
is the hundreds of potential predictors
that were they were out there I'm just
going to show you the top three for each
outcome
so the best predictor according to the
meta-analysis putting all the studies
together of suicide ideation it is prior
suicide ideation followed by
hopelessness followed by a diagnosis of
depression but none of these odds ratios
again are are super high and they start
the tour you know trail off pretty
quickly even by the third third best one
we see something pretty similar for the
best predictors out of again all
possible diagnosis anything anyone's
ever used to predict for suicide attempt
as was mentioned earlier non-suicidal
self-injury actually came out as the
strongest predictor followed by suicide
attempt and screening instruments that
people have used but again you start to
see a trail off pretty quickly after the
first one
really and these aren't in the tens or
the hundreds and for suicide death the
best predictor of future suicide death
is not prior suicide attempt
as is stated and many many different
places is actually having any kind of
history of prior psychiatric
hospitalization and we haven't done the
studies to know to the degree to which
iatrogenic but our thinking right now is
it's probably a really good marker for
people that are have a lot going on or
going through a tough time and maybe
have made a prior attempt but for
whatever reason prior psychiatric
hospitalization seems to be a relatively
strong predictor but I want to emphasize
here that these should not be viewed as
a list of extremely important risk
factors that you should keep track of
and you know to the exclusion of others
whenever you're working with people and
this is because these are only the best
risk factors relative to a bunch of
other extremely weak risk factors in an
absolute sense they're still just not
very good especially whenever you're
thinking about the base rates of suicide
death and an attempt so another way of
putting this is this is kind of like how
I was the best player on my fourth big
grade basketball team
and my mom's opinion anyway so but I was
only the best relative to a bunch of
other extremely unathletic fourth
graders in an absolute sense I was and
still am absolutely terrible at
basketball and so based on existing
research right now what I'm saying is
that all of our individual risk factors
are essentially really unathletic fourth
graders and this includes things like
prior self injurious thoughts behaviors
depression and hopelessness things that
we classically think about individually
at least as they've been studied so far
they're just not gonna be that helpful
for us and a major reason for all of
these very disappointing findings and
how things have been over the last 50
years really we believe is comes down to
our our methods and one issue here is
that we've been testing the same risk
factors over and over again for the last
50 years so what I'm about to show you
is a list of the top 5 most commonly
studied risk factors across each era or
epoch of suicide research so
demographics has always been one of the
most commonly studied internalizing
symptoms followed by social factors
prior self injurious thoughts and
behaviors and external icing symptoms
these five have always been the top five
and they've always accounted for
somewhere between 74 and 80 percent of
all risk factors that people have looked
at so and looking at it like that it
shouldn't really be that surprising that
we haven't gotten much better because
we've been testing the same risk factors
over and over and getting the same
results this has been wonderful for
scientific replication but not great for
for scientific progress so a second
problem that in my opinion might even be
a much larger problem is that we've had
some really homogeneous and somewhat
unfortunate study designs so almost all
of the studies that we looked at I'd say
99% looked at suicide predictors as
isolated trait like phenomena and then
had an average follow-up of about 10
years so based on our meta-analysis what
we know right now is that nothing is a
really good predictor within this kind
of design but we don't really know much
about what predicts well outside of that
kind of design and it's also worth
noting that this kind of design doesn't
really look like anyone's suicide theory
there are very few theories out there
saying there's one thing that never
really changes and over the course of 10
years is going to have this effect
instead most suicide researchers and
even clinicians would say it probably
works a little bit more like this it's
pretty complicated so you have several
distal risk factors some of them are
traits some of them are more state and
several proximal risk factors again some
of them are trait some of these are
state this could be five things three
things a hundred things a thousand
things and they combined together you
know magically and over the course of a
few hours days you know perhaps weeks
they increase risk a bit again sort of
echoing what was talked about this
morning this can change you know moment
to moment but virtually no studies have
tested this kind of model which is the
most common way that most of us might
think about how suicide works so again
we haven't really been testing most of
our theories very well and we haven't
been providing much useful information
for clinicians so what conclusions can
we draw from this well first I really
want to spell out what we believe these
findings do and do not mean because it
can be very easy to misinterpret
I'll start with what they don't mean
that's that this doesn't mean that our
risk factor lists are useless it doesn't
mean that traditional risk factors play
no role in suicidal behaviors doesn't
mean that we should just give up on risk
factors or prediction and likewise it
doesn't mean that we should just focus
exclusively on treatment or perspectives
that would completely issue risk factors
are looking for risk factors what it
does mean is that we should recognize
more formally that our risk factor and
warning sign lists are mostly rationally
derived rather than empirically based
that we pretty much have no idea what
specific role a lot of these factors
play and suicidal behaviors
this is really because our methods just
haven't been capable of telling us much
about these risk factors so our findings
show that we really need a lot more
research on risk factors not less with
the major caveat that this research will
have virtually no value it'll just be a
continuation the patterns I showed you
before
unless much more sensible research
methods are employed and I want to say
here that really what we need to be
looking for our risk algorithms rather
than risk factors per se and I'll say
more about this a couple slides from now
so to summarize here after this massive
meta analytic project in my view this
shows three hard truths about the
suicide prediction field currently
that's first that our ability to predict
suicide really is currently on par with
random guessing for the most part and
second at least with suicide prediction
we haven't really been in a progressive
science even more or less doing the same
studies over and over and over again and
third it seems like we've kind of
forgotten what our our problem really is
and but I mean most of us have been
looking at suicide as what could be
called a simple classification problem
meaning that almost all studies have
again taken this one factor and tried to
use it to accurately predict suicidal
thoughts and behaviors I don't think
that's going to happen and I would guess
that many of you wouldn't as well
because suicide might be best
conceptualized as what's called a
complex classification problem and this
brings me to the second part of the talk
which for the next few minutes I'll
describe how conceptualizing suicide as
more of a complex classification type
problem has already led to some major
advances in the accuracy and scalability
of suicide risk detection so to start
what do I even mean by complex
classification problem well we encounter
these classification problems every day
you've already solved hundreds and
hundreds of them today and you don't
even know it and we solve these with
algorithms which is just a fancy word
for a set of rules or operations so
algorithms can range from being very
very complex to very very simple so an
example of a very simple
classification problem would basically
be classifying dots
as blue or pink it just requires one
factor color pretty simple now a little
bit more difficult one kind of an
intermediate classification problem is
where you need to start considering a
lot of factors all at once and generally
not just simple relationships between
them but it can get more complex for
example trying to determine who should
and should not receive a loan is more of
an intermediate type classification
problem you're going to want to consider
at ten or twenty or thirty factors all
at once and some complex relationships
between them but classification problems
can get a lot more complicated than this
for example internet search queries are
highly complex classification problems
so they're about 1 billion active
websites and several billion active web
web pages being able to identify what a
given user wants based on just a few
words that they type in is an extremely
difficult task but to accomplish this
search engines like Google construct
these algorithms that integrate hundreds
of unique factors at the same time for
example the Google algorithm itself uses
over 200 factors so just typing those
few words in goes through a lot of
things so again that's a very complex
classification problem and I would argue
that the prediction is suicidal behavior
is at least this complex however almost
all existing suicide prediction studies
have treated it much more like a simple
classification problem again almost
always using one sometimes a few factors
at the same time to try and predict
suicidal behaviour so a corollary of
this position again is that instead of
focusing exclusively on risk factors or
what the best risk factor might be we
should probably start prioritizing the
development of highly accurate risk
algorithms now one problem here though
is that the traditional statistical
techniques used in psychology just
aren't well suited to model very very
complex classification problems and
contrast something called machine
learning is optimally suited to do so
and so it's a little bit beyond the
scope of my talk today to give you a
full primer on what machine learning
really is and how it works and all the
many advantages of it but even though
you may not realize it you're all very
very
familiar with machine learning so
machine learning underlies the
algorithms that control your spam
filters for example it's what shows you
the relevant ads online whenever you're
searching things on Google or whenever
you're on Facebook it's what recommends
the correct products to you on Amazon
and it's what corrects your typing
whenever you mess up while texting there
are thousands and thousands more
examples of this basically almost all of
your life is inundated with machine
learning type stuff
it's a subtype of artificial
intelligence but for our purposes today
I just really want to know that there
are three basic advantages for using
machine learning type techniques for
this area of research over traditional
techniques the first is that these
techniques will learn the optimal
algorithm for us we don't have to come
up with a convoluted theory with
hundreds of different factors and figure
out how they work together
it figures that out for us second it can
accommodate a very very large number of
potential predictors and extremely
complex relationships among those
predictors and third machine learning is
really designed with big data and
generalizability in mind and short this
is how myself my colleagues and a few
other groups really think that we should
start predicting suicide and
understanding suicide and use of machine
learning and psychology has really only
started to emerge but in the field of
suicide research there's already been
one really really interesting and
promising study this was led by Kessler
and colleagues published last year and
Janna Psychiatry and basically they
developed an algorithm that gave us a
AUC of 0.85 you can't see that with the
the Mac transition but they had an AUC
of 0.85 to predict suicide death among
soldiers and so again going back to our
you see scale here this actually gets us
more in line what we'd call good
prediction and again remember this is a
major advance because what I described
earlier is that we've been working with
a UCS closer to 0.56 so the Kessler
study really is a major advance relative
to all of that so there are some issues
with that particular study though that
give us a lot of opportunity to improve
upon first that particular algorithm
was developed in a fairly unique sample
army soldiers who are typically more
young and male ii and included several
army specific type factors like age of
enlistment and third it only included 68
suicide deaths which is actually a
fairly high number for our field but
it's still a pretty small number from
which to generalize from and forth the
authors didn't report confidence
intervals and and similar things so it's
hard to know just how robust their
particular estimate was and all of these
things potentially compromise the
generalizability and applicability of
this particular algorithm so my
colleagues and i tried to set out to
advance beyond these kind of limitations
we did this by applying machine learning
to a large regional healthcare system
was called the bio view and this
database includes over a two and a half
million patient participants with full
electronic health records roughly a
thousand are added each week and the
goal of this project was really to to
develop a highly accurate suicide risk
algorithm that was both clinically
useful and widely generalizable and so
our sample for this particular study was
about 3,000 patients about 270 three of
which were suicide decedent's and the
rest were aged and six matched controls
and we applied three machine learning
techniques to our data something called
lasso random forests and send the
college support vector machine or SVM
and it's begun again it's beyond the
scope of this talk to describe exactly
how these work and why they're
interesting and important but there are
two major things that I really want you
to know about this and first is that
each one of these algorithms for one
about to show you included somewhere
between 100 and 355 factors all
integrated at the same time so instead
of using one risk factor to try and
predict suicide
we included hundreds and another thing
is that these are all very different
types of algorithms so if we start to
get similar findings across them all and
that really gives us more confidence
that what we found is something that's
real and robust and not just an artifact
of an interesting method so in terms of
our results we first applied
support vector machine to this and got
an a you see 0.91 which is to be honest
something we were pretty floored by and
to make sure that this was a reliable
estimate we went ahead and checked out
the confidence intervals for that which
were pretty tightly wound around that
then we also ran the other two models
and as you can see highly consistent all
with a UCS in the 90s and for a visual
representation of that this is only
called an ROC curve where this line
right here would represent chance level
prediction with a AUC 0.50 and up here
is where you get perfect prediction and
we're closer to the 1.0 than we are to
the 0.5 which is which is great so all
of these were performing extremely well
it tells us that we can really do a
great job of discriminating who's going
to go on to die by suicide versus who
isn't and because these models basically
use the hospital aged insects match
hospital patients as control the idea
here is that applying this algorithm to
anyone walking to the hospital should
work just as well so within the AUC
scale this moved us more toward
excellent prediction which I honestly
didn't think that we'd really ever get
to and in our field but we're excited to
have some initial work on that but the
results that I just described
compared to aside to students to patient
hospital controls which is good but it's
not the most stringent comparison you
could make and so much more relevant for
many of you is what would happen if we
tried to do the same thing try to
distinguish suicide decisions from
people with a history of suicide
ideation and behavior could we do that
just as well and so we tried that we
reran everything and we had a control
group of about 70,000 or 17,000 people
with some history of suicide ideation or
behavior and the results were
essentially just as good so all a you
sees in the 90s they were actually
slightly better in some ways and this is
the ROC curve depiction of that and
something I haven't really mentioned so
far because it gets too much into the
statistics of it but we also included a
lot of aspects of these techniques that
guarded
against something called overfitting and
basically by going through all of these
other steps and using these techniques
it means that these algorithms are quite
robust it means it should generalize to
any new sample any new group any new
person walking into the hospital so it
wasn't just let's make something that
predicts well for this particular study
and these particular people it's
something that let's make something that
you know more generally could actually
have a larger impact beyond the study so
this is really to us was a very critical
step toward developing a tool that could
very accurately predict suicide risk on
a large scale and the next thing you're
probably wondering is what factors and
these algorithms actually matter before
I answer that question I want to caution
this is kind of like asking what brush
strokes are most important within the
context of a painting and so if I showed
you this it wouldn't really mean that
much in isolation but it's critically
important in the context of something
like van Gogh's a starry night so
basically what I want to convey is that
the individual factors within these
algorithms don't really mean a whole lot
whenever you look at them independent of
the entire context from which they were
developed however a few general types of
effects did tend to emerge across all
the models one was being poor there were
several different indices of this
another was having a lot of physical
health problems especially related to
obesity and and heart issues
another certainly were mental health
issues particularly
mood and substance abuse and another
were famously known problematic
hospitalization patterns like frequent
ER visits and relatively infrequent
outpatient visits I also want to note
something that we found quite important
sort of echoing what was said earlier
again which is that most of the students
in our sample actually didn't have
anything in their history explicitly
about suicidality most were never
flagged as needing any kind of suicide
risk assessment so to us this really
Illustrated that how our traditional
suicide risk attention system works
means that it doesn't even really come
into contact with a lot of those who are
actually truly at high risk so the end
goal of this kind of research is to be
able to stratify risk in real time by
apply
risk algorithms and clinical practice
for example we developing an app that
can immediately tell you a person's
general risk based on the electronic
health record and this could be updated
in real time based on new information
that the patient gives you and we're
working on ways to integrate this into a
large hospitalization hospital systems
right now we think that eventually this
could help us detect millions of people
at high risk who otherwise would have
gone totally undetected and as I round
out this part of my talk today I want to
briefly illustrate how this approach
could be revolutionary for this scale of
suicide detection research so normally
would take thousands thousand people to
assess 1 million patients for a suicide
risk takes us about one person and one
hour to do that and instead of costing
millions and you know millions and
millions of dollars to do that we can do
it for essentially free because there's
just an algorithm that runs through
large medical databases and the accuracy
instead of again being more or less
chance levels is actually pretty
accurate especially for suicidal
thoughts and behaviors so this moves me
to the final part of my talk today where
I want to talk about a new app based
treatment that my colleagues and I
developed and I'll start by briefly
talking about how we developed it and
why and then I'll end pretty quickly
with the results so based on some of my
prior laboratory work we know that most
of us really hate pictures like this and
this is actually a relatively mild
picture compared to some of the other
ones that we have in our studies but I'm
betting that most of you aren't huge
fans in this particular picture but a
lot of people who engage in non-suicidal
self-injury especially if they've done
it very frequently and recently actually
really don't mind these and some of
these actually rate this as being very
pleasant and the more that they tend to
like these pictures we found that the
more likely they are to engage in future
self injurious thoughts and behaviors so
I wondered if it was possible to develop
some kind of intervention that targeted
this particular factor which is you can
think it was kind of an analogue to
Thomas joiner suicidal capability and I
wanted to know if doing this would
actually end up reducing NSSI or
non-suicidal self-injury so to test this
I recruited several people with a
history of NSSI and sent 33 of them
through an aversive conditioning
procedure and 25 of them through
control procedures that I'll call random
conditioning so basically the aversive
conditioning procedure involved
presenting these participants with an
SSI related picture immediately as it
goes off the screen shocking them and
repeating this 18 times within the
context of several stimuli for which
there was no contingency again the idea
here is to try to reestablish a negative
association with those sorts of stimuli
the random auditioning procedure was
essentially the same we just had no
contingencies associated with any of the
pictures and so does this actually have
an effect on and it's as high rates of
the ensuing six months yes so the group
that went through the aversive
conditioning procedure did show
significantly larger drop and SSI over
that same time period
so although this was a very interesting
proof-of-concept type study it's not
really a great solution because shock
therapy isn't palatable it's not
something that I that we set out to
develop or that was the the point of
this particular study and this
intervention just isn't scalable it's
not going to have an impact on national
or international rates of self-injury so
we really needed to find a way to put
this basic concept into an intervention
that was scalable and that's when it
came up with something that we call
therapeutic evaluative conditioning or
te si so to understand what this is it's
helpful to be familiar with the value of
conditioning basically it's just a form
of Pavlovian conditioning that involves
an extra evaluation component meaning
that it leads you to like or dislike
something a bit more and for example if
this blue triangle repeatedly paired
with this image you would start to like
the blue triangle a little bit more over
time and this kind of pairing you would
start to dislike the green circle a
little bit more over time this doesn't
just work with neutral stimuli for
example I really hate vegetables it's
true and you might - if these repeatedly
could welcome to my nightmare
[Music]
so now to the therapeutic part of this
what I just showed you were targets and
unconditioned stimuli you're welcome
again
so to make this therapeutic you just
have to change the the targets so based
on many of our studies we had two main
targets for Tec we wanted basically
people to have more positive
associations with the self and more
negative associations with suicide death
and self-injury stimuli so that's what
Tec is basically designed to do so how
does the app actually work well it's
web-based so accessible from any
particular device very game-like it's
extremely brief just takes a couple
minutes designed for people to play this
hundreds or thousands of times on their
own and it gets a little bit more
challenging as the trials go on so at
the start of each game you're given
three pairs of stimuli the whole point
is to match one of those pairs as
accurately as possible in a given trial
the faster more accurately you do this
the more points that you receive so
about those three pairs one is again
always designed to increase more
negative associations with self-injury
suicide and death one is always there to
establish a more positive association
with the self and one's always going to
be neutral with neutral to increase
variety and difficulty now these are the
three pair types and they're the same
across each game but the specific
stimuli within the types changes
randomly across each game so an actual
trial of Tec will look something like
this just a grid of stimuli and so if
these were the three pairs that you were
given at the start of a particular game
then you would try to click on these as
quickly as possible for that trial these
for this trial and so forth until you
got about 15 trials in where things got
a little bit more difficult where after
you select the first member of the pair
the rest become masked and the idea here
is to increase the depth of processing
to increase the strength of that
Association change and then moves to a
larger grid and then the last 15 trials
was difficult of all of the larger grid
with the masking effect and so over the
past year my team and I conducted three
randomized controlled trials to test the
effectiveness of this on non suicidal
and suicidal self injury inclusion
criteria for the first two studies were
two or more self-cutting episodes over
the last month the last one it was
suicidal behaved in the last year our
ends tend to get larger as the different
studies that we ran even though the
first two studies didn't specifically
select for a history of suicidal
behavior still most of the participants
in the study did have a history of that
and obviously everyone in study three
follow-up rates were pretty good for
this area but I want to note that the
results were essentially the same
whenever we use something called
multiple imputation to make up for any
one that ended up dropping out the
primary outcomes were always the same
with self-cutting suicide plans and
suicidal behaviors and participants were
randomly assigned to receive you the
active version of the intervention which
is what I've just been describing for
the last few minutes with those same
pairings or a control version which is
the exact same except for it just
includes neutral stimuli so we started
at baseline by assessing participants
with the self injurious thoughts and
behaviors interview and then we assessed
our treatment targets with an implicit
version of something called the effect
misattribution procedure and I want to
note that everything presenting today is
actually after accounting for several
major covariance so we followed people
for one month and then measure them on
everything again and during this entire
month they were allowed to play Tec as
often or as little as they would like
and then this way it was much more of an
effectiveness type trial we really
started running his initial studies just
to see if anyone would even do this but
I will note that even though these are
more route based effects that the more
that people played the the stronger the
effects tended to be so what effects did
this type of intervention actually have
on our primary outcomes well here on the
y-axis we have the percent reduction
behaviors and the active group so our
treatment group compared to the control
group and in study one we saw a pretty
nice significant reduction and
self-cutting behaviors pretty nice
significant reduction in suicide plans
and suicidal behaviors and actually to
be honest as were far far larger effects
than what we were expecting which made
us think we did something wrong or this
was a huge fluke so we immediately just
ran another study that was as close to
that study as we could make it and sure
enough the effects were a bit weaker
with the
plans being non-significant but they
were still in the same directions there
still appear to be something there and
just to see if study one was too
optimistic or study two was too
pessimistic we ran that third study and
it looks like the truth is probably
somewhere in between where this does
seem to have a real nice effect although
I'll note that this was just during the
treatment month for the month after that
a lot of these effects tended to go away
and so you tended to need to be playing
this in order for it to have its
therapeutic effects and also note that
there were only about 30 or so suicidal
behaviors and each one of these studies
and that made us a bit nervous about
interpreting those effects so one of the
things that we did is decide to combine
those across studies we wind up with 91
total suicidal behaviors and then
whenever you look at those across groups
obviously it wasn't an equal
distribution because we have a treatment
effect 74 and the control group and 17
and the active group and during the
course of that month across all three
studies so what we have so far I think
is extremely promising but I want to
emphasize that these are just the first
steps with these kinds of approaches for
both risk detection and prevention we
still have a ton of work that we want to
do a lot of improvements that we have to
make and right now our future and
ongoing work is really focused on trying
to do those things and make those
improvements but hopefully soon this
kind of work will actually start
translating into changing this century
or longer old trend of suicide death and
suicide attempts and on suicidal
self-injury so thank you all for
listening and thanks very much to my
colleagues who actually made all this
work possible
Thank You dr. Franklin so we have a
couple of questions from the audience
and we just have a couple minutes so
we'll ask a few of them there was one
question about the machine learning
study how did you guys choose the
factors that you decided to finally
include in the algorithm what was your
basis for choosing this the short answer
to that is that the algorithm
essentially chooses them for us and so
we gave it seven hundred and something
to choose from and then it's likely the
ones that were significant and then
something called a cross validation
sample to see if it's significant and
both samples and if it is then it wound
up being included in the model and so
that's one area I didn't have time to
explain but basically the Machine
figures out the optimal algorithm and
configuration for us and was any kind of
family history or anything like that
included in those or were they mainly
medical records that's a great question
what we were really wanting to do with
this initial effort here is create
something that was gonna be replicable
across most system so at Vanderbilt they
have a whole bioinformatics group that
does a lot of this great work and stuff
like natural language processing that
can get a lot more complicated a lot of
genetics work but we wanted this to be
something that and pretty much anyone's
electronic health record and any system
out there that you could just apply this
to that so it was just the intentionally
just the very basic types of diagnosis
and codes and have you so it sounds like
I guess there was a question from the
audience about the generalizability or
the applicable atif or BPD do you think
that this that your treatment
intervention the therapeutic the TEC do
you think that that could be used with
the PD or do you think that there might
be issues with seeing images that might
maybe confound the effects you found
it's a good question I think so we
didn't ask it and particularly in this
study
but I I know just and going back and
forth participants that a lot of them
said that they had been diagnosed with
BPD but certainly we cautioned far and
wide for these kind of studies for what
they're going to see and so we had
people select in the study if they were
already okay with seeing it so it is
unclear what happened but I think
they're a bunch of ways to use these
general types of conditioning principles
to get around that for certain people
well thank you very much thank you all
[Applause]
[Music]